have you seen anything at this point
that gives you a high degree of
confidence that the Wuhan instituted
virology was the origin of this virus
yes yes I am and I think that the World
Health Organization should be ashamed of
themselves
because they're like the public
relations agency for China and this
country pays them almost 500 million
dollars a year and China pays them 38
million dollars a year and whether it's
a lot or more doesn't matter it's still
they shouldn't be making excuses when
people make horrible mistakes especially
mistakes that are causing hundreds of
thousands of people around the world to
die
you